when did you figure out that it was
working that this was a great combo you
and Sean
when I saw our songs kind of like
neck-and-neck on the chart yeah and I
said to myself whoever who who's Asian
ever decided to put this together should
get like you know a piece of cake or
something like that good job now they
are nekkid out who's who's who's above
right now give any idea not that it
matters but I think I am right not that
it matters at all he's doing you know
sold-out arenas yeah do you follow that
stuff because you will get so much going
on and the Machine sort of behind you
and behind this tour like who's the one
who tells you the status of a song and
how a song is doing it does it even
matter
hmm usually my manager yeah my manager
Ron or my label head Mike my radio lady
Andrea so a lot of people a lot of
people I I and I'm you know I'm also
checking it too because you know I'm
producing these records again the ground
up so it's a it's kind of cool to see
how they react with people right when
you do share so much of an audience with
the person you're you're touring with I
mean as an opening act it's must not
seem at times that you are actually an
opening act it's uh I like to I like to
think that I still still am technically
but uh it's I I remember asking Sean the
first night do people usually come out
for the people who start off the show
and he was like yeah it'll be full for
you right what do you mean like nobody
knows me and then I went out and then I
you know ate my words yeah it was that
like when you when you're there and you
know you've worked so hard on a song and
you're in a city you've never been in
before and yet you see people singing
your lyrics back to you
it's uh I think of the Internet and how
amazing that is because I'm I'm a geek
at heart and it's just amazing that
everybody has a cell phone and everybody
has a computer and everybody is able to
just like pull up attention and listen
to it yeah it just goes widespread they
the other night they were singing back
the the verse to me usually they sing
back the chorus they say like the whole
verse I didn't have to sing half asana
you were talking about being a geek in
computers and everything else at what
point did you realize that see you again
was going to hit three billion I mean I
have no idea I think when I saw it hit
three billion it seemed like that for
somebody who spent so much time on
YouTube just doing whatever you're doing
on Tula do you spend a lot of people
obviously spent a lot of time I need to
but what does that like to know in the
ranking of every single thing that you
have watched and everybody else in the
world has watched it's cool it's a cool
thing it's uh I started my channel ten
years ago thinking uh it would be cool
to get 10,000 hits and now there's a
video with me and it's 3 billion 3
billion have you figured out have you
been able to deconstruct what it was
about that track that made it into the
sort of monster that it was the chord
changes yep yeah the b-flat major if a
chord change if a human is listening to
a record and they can predict they might
not know how to explain it but they can
kind of like feel and while they're
listening to a piece of music they can
feel where it's going yeah if whether
it's like FS s to b-flat major it's it's
just Church chordal based music so G
minor B flat major E flat major B flat
major it lyrically it's a sad sad yet
uplifting song and it's the same
reflects on the chord changes of the the
piano too so when I play the G minor
it's a very sad chord B flat major
little hint of uplifting a flat major
again and the B flat major and then G
minor sad but so it
lyrics and the chords directly mirror
each other so and I guess when people
listen to that they can kind of see and
feel where the music's going it sounds
almost manipulative in a way you have to
like figured out yeah you know what a
when you're well I make music for people
in people's reactions so when I'm when I
produce see you again I wanted I there
was a video of this huge festival with
500,000 people screaming along the
lyrics it's and they can they're all
singing along it's been a lot any the
guys and the girls can hit that range
perfectly together
so when guys and girls the same thing
with like you know like Bruce
Springsteen music everyone really hot
guys and girls can sing that and that
range so it's all math really when
you're producing out a record I can go
on about this forever